quand je vous parlais d'édition beatbox
sur le Galaxy Z flip 4 regardez un peu
toutes les différentes combinaisons de
couleurs qu'on peut avoir entre le
panneau arrière le panneau avant il y en
a en haut il y en a en bas donc si vous
voulez vous amuser à venir personnaliser
ce smartphone et vous avez de quoi faire
donc là vraiment je sais pas ce que vous
vous en pensez est-ce que vous pourrez
mettre comme couleur personnellement je
resterai convaincu que c'était espèce de
petit framboise là avec le petit panneau
framboise c'est hyper canon qu'est-ce
que j'aime bien j'aime bien espèce de
bleu foncé qu'on a aussi ici là un peu
moins celui-là et à l'arrière avec le
Petit Bleu français je les mettrai le
petit le petit le petit dos qui va avec
je sais pas quel est votre configuration
préférée dites le modèle